memorandum of understanding on a
strategic partnership in the field of
energy between the republic of
azerbaijan and the european union
represented by the european commission
[Applause]
so
um
and president of the european commission
dear madam president dear ladies and
gentlemen uh first of all i'd like to
welcome madam president of european
commission to azerbaijan
and delegation from eu today we
had very good discussions on broad range
of issues of mutual interest
we covered all the topics which today
are on our agenda
and we had the ceremony of signing the
mou
on strategic partnership in the field of
energy between european union and
azerbaijan
our active cooperation in energy area
already has a history of more than 15
years
today's memorandum is not the first
document which was signed between us we
had
mou signed in 2006 and joined
declaration on thousand gas corridor
signed in 2010
so we have a good history and good
achievements and
energy projects initiated by azerbaijan
and supported by european
union and
supported by our partners completely
changed the energy map
of europe
we started with oil production
and then gas production and construction
of oil pipeline which connected caspian
with black sea and mediterranean
and of course thousand gas corridor
which
is a 3 500 kilometers long
integrated pipeline system which brings
our gas to european continent and it's
less than two years that thousand gas
corridor works uh in full capacity
and with all of all the segments are in
place but already we see
the
positive benefits of this cooperation
issues of energy security today are more
important than ever before
and
long lasting
predictable
and very reliable cooperation between eu
and azerbaijan
in the field of energy of course is a
big asset
this year we started energy dialogue
between eu and azerbaijan which covers
many
areas including oil gas renewables
hydrogen energy efficiency
and other issues
and the great potential of renewable
energy production in azerbaijan also is
appreciated already by european union we
already started projects of
investments
in wind and solar energy
we already made the first assessment
about our potential
and i can say that in the
liberated areas of karabakh and eastern
zengizu the potential of solar and
wind power plants is nine thousand
two hundred megawatts and the potential
of the of wind in the caspian sea
is
157 gigawatts so we have really enormous
resource base
plus of course new gas fields which we
will
engage in coming years will add
to the production of natural gas and
using renewables
will save more natural gas for experts
so it's
very
advantageous situation which was built
by our efforts and supported by european
union
and today's memorandum actually is a
kind of a road map for the future
and taking into account that all what we
planned before we accomplished i'm sure
that we'll see a great success
among other issues which we discussed
today was
uh issue of connectivity and taking into
account geographical location of
azerbaijan and modern transportation
infrastructure
we need to work more actively on
connecting
our potential because here on the
western shore of the caspian azerbaijan
have the biggest trade fleet in the
caspian modern infrastructure
shipbuilding yard
new seaport and railroad connecting us
with all our neighbors
and there is a big demand to
have joint efforts in order to make
connectivity as important in our
relationship as energy
of course our
agenda is very broad
we are working on a new agreement
between you and azerbaijan we just
discussed it with madam president and
hopefully in coming months we
we can complete it
and uh
that will also be important contribution
to our bilateral cooperation
we work
on bilateral track within the framework
of eastern partnership
program and
eu is the main trading partner for
azerbaijan
implementing
our plans of course will increase the
joint turnover to the benefit of our
peoples
and the relationship between eu and
azerbaijan i'm sure will have
a great future and all what we plan we
will achieve
once again madam president thank you for
being with us and wish you a pleasant
stay in baku thank you very much mr
president for the very warm welcome here
in baku
and thank you for stepping up and
supporting the european union
because already before russia's brutal
invasion in ukraine
the russian gas supplies to europe were
no more reliable
and the european union has therefore
decided to diversify away from russia
and to turn to more towards more
reliable trustworthy partners
and i'm glad to count azerbaijan among
them
you are indeed
a crucial energy partner for us and you
have always been reliable
not only for our security of supply you
are a crucial partner but also in our
efforts to become climate neutral
the memorandum of understanding that we
have just signed makes our energy
partnership even stronger i want to
emphasize three points from our
memorandum of understanding
the first is that we will double the
supply of gas from azerbaijan to the
european union
indeed with this mou we commit to the
expansion of the southern gas corridor
this is already a very important supply
road route for the european union
delivering currently more than 8 bcm
billion cubic meters of gas per year
and we will expand its capacity to 20
billion cubic meters in a few years
from next year on we should already
reach 12 billion cubic meters this will
help compensate for cuts in supplies of
russian gas
and contribute significantly to europe's
security of supply the second point that
is very prominent in the mou
is
the topic of the renewables
azerbaijan has a tremendous potential in
renewable energy you just describe it mr
president
and in particular in offshore wind and
green hydrogen we discussed it
extensively in our bilateral meeting
today with our mou we are laying the
ground for solid cooperation in that
area
so gradually
azerbaijan will evolve from being a
fossil fuel supplier to becoming a very
reliable and prominent renewable energy
partner to the european union
and finally
our cooperation on gas has to be
consistent with our responsibilities on
climate
this includes for example the emissions
of methane
our mou sets out commitments to reduce
methane emissions throughout the entire
gas supply chain
and as we have discussed mr president i
strongly encourage other beijing to join
the global methane pledge which is now
supported by 119 countries azerbaijan
has made enormous progress and has a lot
to show and to deliver
indeed beyond energy
president alief and i discussed the full
range of our
relation and cooperation
the eu azerbaijan corporation council
will meet tomorrow in brussels
and discuss how to take forward our
bilateral cooperation
we are working right now on a new
bilateral agreement that we hope to
conclude soon
the aim is to further expand the strong
economic partnership we do have
indeed the european union is the first
commercial partner of azerbaijan
the first export destination
and one of its most important sources of
investment and this we want to expand
we are investing 60 million euros of eu
funds in azerbaijan azerbaijan till 2024
and the economic and investment plan has
the potential to mobilize up to 2
billion euros in additional investment
it is already at work
supporting around about 25 000 azir
azeri small and medium companies
and making the port of baku a
sustainable transport hub
this is for us very important because
this leads indeed to the topic of
connectivity you have been mentioning
we also discussed that in particular how
to deepen our ties
to bring our people and societies closer
together
this is the mission of our global
gateway strategy and this is also the
essence of our eastern partnership
the european union wants to work with
azerbaijan to build connections with
central asia asia and beyond
so we follow with great interest the
discussions and the ideas about
trans-caspian connections we will deepen
these con these discussions
finally
we want to finalize the common aviation
area agreement because this would
greatly boost opportunities for business
trade and for tourism
to reach azerbaijan's full potential it
is important to create the right
conditions for investor confident
this includes a great involvement of
civil society and a free and independent
media
the european union is committed to a
secure stable and prosperous south
caucasus
we are the leading donor in mining in
the country for example we have also
discussed this very important topic we
have now just announced a new
4.25 million euro package for this
purpose
but we are also willing to offer
machinery and skills in this very
important field
all in all the european union is firmly
firmly attached to your region mr
president we value our partnership and
this partnership will consistently grow
and deepen over time thank you very much
again for hosting us here and thank you
very much for the
joint signing of the moyu thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you